oh here's somebody right here who's
obviously uh there's someone with the
same nose as theo
[Laughter]
guys save some auction for the rest of
oh gosh
hey what's up brandon theo and the gang
i got a quick uh
king interstinger for you i'm out here
in amish country ohio
this is where i'm from uh you see the
people on the buggies you'll see them on
bikes i even saw a guy pushing a razor
scooter to get to work
so the king of sting it is the amish
lifestyle would you live it
no electricity uh no cars a simple life
let me know what you think gang gang
buzz buzz
buzz man gang dang i'm a sly
that's not near lancaster out there i
think in pa do you say he's in pa where
he is ohio yeah totally different
close though
um i don't know what do you think about
the almost lifestyle chappelle what do
you think
i like a simple life i don't need much i
don't even have a car
yeah you know yeah gold you know if
you're if you're in the amish lifestyle
you're having a gold chain yeah right
now
i can't have a gold chain no you can't
wear it doesn't cortez nike's either
no dog can't wear any of that stuff you
ever seen a
fly [ __ ] amish person
you ever seen an amish person somehow i
mean i've seen i've seen kingpin you
ever seen that movie
great you know oh someone so overrated
or underrated i don't know which one
means underrated
sorry bill murray and that's so funny oh
is his players all [ __ ] up
oh cat you could do it huh um
i feel like i could probably do it just
because my
i imagine that's how my parents lived in
vietnam but
i don't think i could do it now yeah
yeah it's crazy how like your parents
will be will live one life and then the
kids will live
and just how different it is you know
and how i refuse to go camping
yeah yeah yeah camp it's like being home
it's just like being just briefly amish
don't they send their kids out when they
turn 18 to like springer
yeah it's on the screen that's where it
goes from springer
so you get a chance to stunt and live a
lifestyle for a little while come back
do you have to come back no uh no it's
like up to you it's like
a trial period and they build all their
own [ __ ] too right
yeah they turn their own butter they
probably have no idea what's going on
right now
a lot of people in like my area they buy
their furniture from amish people
because it's all handcrafted and stuff
like they probably have no idea about
cobin that's a good question
like why are they waiting [ __ ] mass
these days yeah are the amish getting
covered can you look that up
that's been a tough sell how long are
their kids allowed to leave for like
when they turn 18.
ooh lancaster county that's where
they're at
pandemic taking toll on amish oh look at
that well damn look at that little
freaking nest chin
your chin is in that little thing if we
can zoom in on there we'll see him
nothing's sick
oh yeah i do love carhartt it looks like
he's got
yelling at us
oh wow okay
what it hit the amish dude it did well
what did that say we didn't even see it
right it's red amongst the amish
yeah we didn't read it yeah dude read
the [ __ ] top line that son
yeah that's just the bait my trend
upward will increase about
135 percent statewide you know that
doesn't matter
i guess so how'd they get it if they
don't talk to anyone they're
they don't remember some facts about
driving yeah i don't know man i said
this state that the person home
infections were the driving numbers
there ah [ __ ] get out of here
it's nursing homes that's not amish yeah
a lot of the amsterdam we don't even
know then it says we don't know because
a lot of the amateurs are not being
tested they're choosing not to be tested
yet because they don't have it don't
[ __ ] with us
damn good for them like we don't have
your [ __ ] disease do they do they let
outsiders come in there
in their in their town a lot about amish
yeah
we should get an amish person on right
they wouldn't do it
you don't think no dude but somebody
that went to rum springer and then gay
came out and they came out you talked to
someone who's changed who grew up in
that lifestyle
yeah oh maybe that guy who sent in the
video
oh yeah yeah with his nose yeah i wish i
had that little nose he has
i got this intake man
i got this air filter
[Music]
is